mit bürgerinnen und liebe mitbürger wir
sind heute in einer anderen welt
aufgewacht nach monaten der vorbereitung
von lügen und propaganda hat präsident
putin heute nacht entschieden seinen
drogen schreckliche taten folgen zu
lassen mit dem militärischen angriff auf
die ukraine bricht die russische
regierung vor den augen der welt mit den
elementarsten regeln der internationalen
ordnung
russland allein hat diesen weg gewählt
wir haben in den vergangenen monaten
nichts unversucht gelassen um auch
diplomatischen wege eine friedliche
lösung für diese russland krise zu
finden
russland ist auf unsere
gesprächsangebote nicht eingegangen die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer haben nichts
getan was dieses blutvergießen
rechtfertigt dieser krieg soll vor allem
eins zerstören die hoffnung der menschen
in der ukraine
dass sie nach jahrzehnten der unfreiheit
ein recht auf demokratie ein recht auf
frieden und auf eine bessere zukunft
ohne unterdrückung haben
präsident putin diesen traum werden sie
niemals zerstören können er wächst in
der ukraine erwächst genauso in ihrem
land ich bin überzeugt auch in russland
werden viele menschen sich dafür schämen
und darüber empören dass in dem namen
russlands auf jahrzehnte mit kuppel
losen mord an ihren früheren und
schwestern in der ukraine beschädigt
wurde
liebe mitbürgerinnen liebe mitbürger wir
alle sind heute morgen fassungslos aber
wir sind nicht hilflos wir haben uns auf
diese ereignisse vorbereitet und werden
nun gemeinsam mit unseren partnern und
alliierten vorgehen und wird dabei jeden
meter mit unseren freundinnen und
freunden in der ukraine abstimmen wir
werden uns heute im rahmen der eu im
rahmen der nato im rahmen der g7
koordinieren wir werden das volle paket
mit massivsten sanktionen gegen russland
auf den weg bringen und wir werden
unsere sicherheit und unsere
bündnispartner stärken aber heute geht
es nicht nur um europa kein land der
welt kann akzeptieren dass die
souveränität anderer zur disposition
steht wenn's ein stärkerer nachbar es
will mit unseren diplomatischen netzen
in der ganzen welt wenden wir uns jetzt
an alle staaten die wie wir an die
charta der vereinten nationen glauben
sich gemeinsam dieser aggression
entgegen zu stellen
liebe deutsche staatsangehörige in der
ukraine
verlassen sie unverzüglich die ukraine
im interesse ihrer eigenen sicherheit
dazu haben wir sie in den letzten tagen
bereits mehrfach aufgefordert falls sie
das land nicht auf einen sicheren weg
verlassen können bleiben sie vorläufig
an einem geschützten ort
wir haben eine krisenhotline für
deutsche staatsangehörige in der ukraine
geschaltet sie sie können sie unter 0 30
5000 3000 jederzeit erreichen
organisierte transporte sind derzeit
nicht möglich unsere auslandsvertretung
in polen der slowakei ungarn und moldau
stehen bereit um ab der grenze
unterstützung zu leisten
mit unseren europäischen nachbarn haben
wir uns darauf gemeinsam lange
vorbereitet
tragen sie sich bitte in die online
krisenvorsorge liste des auswärtigen
amtes ein sollten sie bereits die
ukraine verlassen haben tragen sie sich
bitte aus dieser liste wieder aus
verfolgen sie die internationalen und
lokalen medien und achten sie auch auf
lokale bekanntmachung ich habe schon
gestern abend entschieden dass das noch
verbliebene entsandte personal der
deutschen botschaft in kiew aus
sicherheitsgründen abgezogen wurde wir
werden lageabhängig entscheiden ob die
botschaft ihrer arbeit vorübergehend von
lemberg oder von anderswo aufnehmen kann
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
dieser krieg in unserer direkten
nachbarschaft wird auch für uns in
deutschland folgen
die sanktionen gegen russland steigende
preise und feine aktienmärkte werden
auch rückwirkungen auf deutschland haben
wir haben uns diese situation nicht
ausgesucht wir können aber wir wollen
auch nicht ihr aus dem weg gehen die
europäische friedensordnung der letzten
jahrzehnte ist die grundlage für das
leben in wohlstand und in frieden wenn
wir jetzt nicht entschlossen dafür
eintreten werden wir einen noch höheren
preis bezahlen
herzlichen dank
die außenministerin muss weiter ins
sicherheitskabinett deswegen haben wir
leider keine zeit für fragen vielen dank